Building on the last video, let's look at the scenario using the provided project named Bear CP.
It shows point cloud data of a bear model processed from both top and bottom.
In essence, it's the exact scenario and the exact workflow that you had tried with the line in the last video.
Yet, after scanning both sides and creating masks, which gets you to this point where the project was saved,
aligning the cameras again, as you did before, doesn't work in this instance.
Instead of ending up with a single component and a single finalized point cloud,
you still get two unfused components of the bear.
When this happens, you need to help the process a little bit by using control points.
Control points are points that you explicitly identify on multiple components to help bring parts together.
There are usually points of high contrast, but in this case, things were made easier with pieces of tape.
Select component 0, representing the top of the bear. You'll target the left hind leg first.
From the Alignment tab, choose Add Control Points.
As you hover over the left hind leg, rays appear in the 3D view, representing the cameras that can see that point.
Click a point in that area. You don't need to be accurate at this time.
Right-click to end the command. A new point named Point 0 has been created.
Several images that can be used to track this point have also been identified.
Select the first image in that list. This switches you to a three-pane layout.
Point 0 can now be seen in both the 3D and 2D views.
In the 2D view, you need to relocate Point 0 to the reference point with a click and drag to bring it to the corner of the red triangle.
Once this is done, you can do the same with the other images, but here's a trick.
As you are relocating the image reference with a click and drag, do not release the mouse button.
Use the down arrow key to move to the next image in line. This can be a great time saver.
Once you have a few references in place, you need to pinpoint them on the pictures taken from the bottom half.
So select component 1, representing the bottom half of the bear.
Also, and this is crucial, you want to ensure that Point 0 is selected in the list, otherwise hitting add control points would actually create a new point.
And orbit around to view the left hind leg. This may be a bit harder to visualize as the bear is upside down.
With that done, Point 0 selected that is, use add control points and click a point on the left hind leg on the upside down model.
Again, right-click to exit the command. A few more reference images have been added to the Point 0 list.
Go ahead and adjust them as you did before, and keep in mind that as you relocate them, other images may be identified.
Once you go through this process, chances are there may be some hits and misses.
The misses are represented by red or yellow icons, basically errors or warnings.
You could try and reposition them, but often, you typically have more than enough reference points that you can remove the bad ones.
Once you have done so, and there are no more reported errors, you can move on to the next point.
For that, you may want to start again with component 0, but more importantly, you don't want Point 0 to be selected in the list.
You actually want to create a new point this time around, so make sure Point 0 is unselected by selecting any image reference underneath.
Let's move to the left front leg. Add a control point there near the green mark.
A new point, Point 1, is created, and you can repeat the procedure to adjust the reference points.
Once done, on the upper half of the bear, select the bottom component and make sure Point 1 is selected.
Again, you want to identify Point 1 on the bottom half of the bear, so it's important you have the point selected this time.
Use Add Control Points one more time to add references to the bottom half, and adjust them as you did before.
You now have two control points, identified on the two halves of the model, on one side of the bear.
The more control points you have, the better success you will achieve.
There are four color dots on this model, but three of them should be enough for a good triangulation, so let's do one more.
Again, select component 0 and make sure Point 1 is not selected by selecting one of its reference images.
Add a new control point, perhaps for the right-hand leg near the white marker.
Right-click to end the command. Re-align the reference images and clean up any errors or warnings.
When done, select component 1 and make sure Point 2 is selected this time.
Use Add Control Points to identify image references for that point on the bottom half of the bear.
Adjust the positioning as you have learned to do.
At this stage, you should have enough information with three control points to rebuild the point cloud.
You can switch back to a 2D pane layout.
To build the final solution, you only need to use the Merge Components tool in the Alignment tab.
This will use the information you have set up using control points to fuse the two halves of the bear together.
It will create a new component, component 01 in this case, that you can adjust to your liking.
I would suggest the usual, using Set Ground Plane to reorient it, meshing it with normal detail,
perhaps decimating the triangle count and smoothing it, and of course texturing it before you are ready for export.
As you orbit around, you will see that the process worked perfectly.
The last video will be a bit of a bonus.
In it, you learn how you can re-process a model in RealityCapture after you have manipulated it in a GCC application.